This lecture is about the smoothing of
language models.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue talking about probabilistic
retrieval model.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the smoothing of language model in
the query likelihood retrieval method.
So you have seen this slide from the
previous lecture.
This is the ranking function based on
the query likelihood.
Here we assume that the independence of
generating each query word.
And the formula would look like the
following where we take a sum over
all the query words and inside the sum.
There is a log of probability of word
given by the document or document
language model.
So the main task now is to estimate
this document language model.
As we said before, different methods
for estimating this model would lead to
different retrieval functions.
So in this lecture we're going to look
into this in more detail.
So how do we estimate this language
model?
The obvious choice would be the maximum
likelihood estimate that we have seen
before, and that is we're going to
normalize the word frequencies in the
document.
And the estimated probability would
look like this.
But this is a step function here.
Which means all the words that have the
same frequency count will have
identical probability.
Right, this is another frequent account that
has a different probability.
Note that for words that have not
occurred in the document here they all
have zero probability, so we this know this is
just like the model that we assumed
earlier in the lecture, where we assume
that the user would sample word from
the document.
To formulate a query.
And there's no chance of sampling any
word that's not in the document, and we
know that's not good.
So how do we improve this, well?
In order to assign a non zero
probability to words that have not been
observed in the document.
We would have to take away some
probability mass from the words that
are observed in the document.
So for example here we have to take
away some probability mass because
we need some extra probability mass for
the unseen words.
Otherwise they want to sum to one.
So all these probabilities must sum to
one.
So to make this transformation and to
improve the maximum likelihood estimate by
assigning non zero probabilities to
words that are not observed in the
data.
We have to do smoothing and smoothing
has to do with improving the estimate
by considering the possibility that if the
author had been written had been asked
to write more words.
For the document, the author might have
written other words.
If you think about this factor, then a
smoother language model would be more
accurate representation of the actual
topic.
Imagine you have seen an abstract
of a research article.
Let's say this document is abstract.
Right, if we assume.
unseen words in this abstract.
We have all probability of zero.
That would mean there is no chance of
sampling a word outside the abstract
to formulate a query.
But imagine a user who is interested in
the topic of this subject.
The user might actually choose a word
that's not in the abstract to use as
query.
So obviously if we had asked this
author to write more, the author would have
written the full text of that article.
So smoothing of the language model is
attempt to try to recover the model for
the whole article and then of course we
don't have really knowledge about any
words that are not observed in the
abstract there.
So that's why smoothing is actually
tricky problem.
So let's talk a little more about how
to smooth the language model.
And the key question here is what
probability should be assigned to those
unseen words.
And there are many different ways of
doing that.
One idea here that's very useful for
retrieval is let the probability of
unseen word be proportional to its
probability given by reference language
model.
That means if we don't observe the
word in the data set, we're going to
assume that it's probability is kind of
governed by another reference language
model that we will construct.
It will tell us which unseen words will
have likely higher probability.
In the case of retrieval, a natural
choice would be to take the collection
language model as the reference
language model.
That is to say if we don't observe a word
in the document.
We're going to assume that the
probability of this word would be
proportional to the probability of the
word in the whole collection.
So more formally, we will be estimating
the probability of a word given
a document as follows.
If the word is seen in the document.
Then the probability would be a
discounted.
maximum likelihood estimate P sub
seen here.
Otherwise.
If the word is not seen in the
document, we're going to let its
probability be proportional to the
probability of the word in the
collection.
And here the coefficient Alpha.
Is to control the amount of probability
mass that we assign to unseen words.
Obviously, all these probabilities must
sum to one, so Alpha sub D is
constrained in some way.
So what if we plug in this smoothing
formula into our query likelihood running
function?
This is what we will get.
Right, in this formula you can see.
Right, we have.
This as a sum over all the query words
and note that we have written in the
form of a sum over all the vocabulary.
Can see here this is a sum over all the
words in the vocabulary, but note that
we have a count of the word in the
query.
So in effect we are just taking sum of
query words right?
This is now.
A common way that we will use.
Because of its convenience.
In some transformations.
So this is as I said, this is some
of all the query words.
In our smoothing method, we assume that
the words that are not observed in the
document we have somewhat different
form of probability namely it's for this
form.
So we're going to then decompose this
sum into two parts.
One sum is over all the query words that
are matching the document. That means in this sum, all the words have a non-zero probability
in the document, sorry it's the non 0 count
of the word in the document.
They all occurred in the document.
And they also have to of course have a
non 0 count in the query, so these are
the words that are matched.
These are the query words that are
matching the document.
But on the other hand, in this sum
we are taking sum over all the words
that are not.
All query words that are not matched in
the document.
So they occur in the query.
Due to this this term, but they don't occur
in the document.
In this case, these words have this
probability because of our assumption
about the smoothing.
But that here.
These seen words have a different
probability.
Now we can go further by rewriting the
second sum.
As a difference of two other sums,
basically the first sum is actually
sum,
over all the query words.
We know that the original sum is not
This is over all the
query words that are not matched in the
document.
So here we pretend that they are
actually.
Over all the query words, so we take a
sum over all the query words.
Obviously this sum has extra terms that
are.
This sum has extra terms that are not
in this sum.
Because here we are taking sum over all
the query words there.
It's not matched in the document.
So in order to make them equal, we will
have to then subtract another sum
here.
And this is the sum over all the query
words that are matching the document.
And this makes sense, because here we
are considering all query words and
then we subtract the query words that
are matched in the document.
That would give us the query words that
not matched in the document.
And this is almost reverse process of
the first step here.
And you might want to, why do we want
to do that?
Well, that's cause.
If we do this, then we have different
forms of terms inside these sums.
So now you can see in this sum we
have.
All the words match
the query words matched in the document
and with this kind of terms.
Here we have another sum.
Over the same set of terms.
match the query terms in document but
inside the sum it's different.
But these two sums can clearly be
merged.
So if we do that, we'll get another
form of the formula that looks like the
following.
At the bottom here.
And note that this is a very
interesting formula because here we
combined these two.
That our sum.
Over the query words matched in the
document in the one sum here.
And the other sum now is decomposed
into two parts.
And these two parts look much simpler
just because these are the
probabilities of unseen worlds.
Now this formula is very interesting
because you can see the sum is now over
all the matched query terms.
And just like in the vector space
model, we take a sum of terms that are
in the intersection of query vector and
the document vector.
So it all already looks a little bit like the
vector space model.
In fact, there's even more similarity
here as we explain on this slide.